what do you think happens after death oh
that's not an easy question I do not
know the answer to that okay but I know
that we don't we never really die I know
that was science I'm so so understand
this huh I'm dead center between EQ and
IQ but I've learned through the modern
world to prioritize my IQ to prioritize
logic right and so every single thing I
say in solve for happy and all of my
lectures or teachings or whatever I
avoid going to my spiritual side because
I want to remain objective there are so
many people in the world that can talk
about things from a spiritual point of
view I want to be the objective one that
talks about it from science I I don't
know if we have the time for this but if
you truly understand the theory of
relativity if you truly understand
space-time continuum if you truly
understand that time does not really
exist in the form that we understand it
does you have to start questioning who
died first me or Allie who lived first
in your alley first or last is a
property of the physical it's a property
of this physical world
if space-time continuum exists and I can
actually perceive time that must mean I
have a vantage point that stays with
outside time a vantage point is a
prerequisite to perception I cannot
perceive this building if I'm inside it
for me to perceive this building I have
to be outside it for us to see planet
Earth we had to send people outside or
machines outside right if you're within
time you wouldn't perceive time the
reason why we perceive the arrow of time
is because we reside outside space-time
the real us resides outside place
space-time and and most of us don't
realize then they seal us oh yeah this
is the avatar this is the avatar is this
truly is the avatar wash vehicle this me
this is this is the the vehicle that you
the physical vehicle you use to navigate
the physical form the physical world
right it's the avatar that you're
sitting somewhere else with the control
right otherwise you wouldn't perceive
any of this you could not perceive it if
you're inside it the other side of it
huh if you if you combine quanta
physics with with the Big Bang Theory
you start to realize the simplest things
that science ignores to mention for some
reason we big banks has 13.7 billion
years ago there was a tiny mass that
compressed enough and then exploded into
gases and then condensed into planets
and other objects right 4.3 billion
years ago there was planet Earth it
cooled down and then over 400 you know I
think 3.9 billion of those years there
was no life and then life started to
show or whatever the numbers are please
don't quote me on the numbers but
they're within those ranges quantum
physics on the other hand will tell you
that nothing actually exists in its
particle form until observed so who was
observing this for the first thirteen
billion years life has always existed
somehow in some form and so what I can
tell you is this with certainty that
death is not the opposite of life death
is the opposite of birth you come into
this world through a portal that we call
birth you leave this physical form
through a portal that we call death but
life exists before during and after
right now when you think about it this
way you realize that what died is my
son's physical form and you know what is
the only thing that is certain unless
you'll find the miracle somehow is that
I will die too okay
this physical form will go to the only
certainty is that wherever Allie is now
I will be too right whatever that is and
the journey between now and then might
be a year ten twenty thirty in the
absence of time and the relativity of
time it will go like this
and we all know that I'm you know you
just look back at your last thirty years
and ask yourself how quickly they passed
now blink of an eye blink of an eye now
fast and hopefully there's more life
after the portal of so so what happens
after
is really where I somehow blame
spirituality because some of them will
say with certainty it's reincarnation
others will say with certainty it's life
you know heaven and hell and we don't
have proof of that but does it really
matter if you're a video gamer and you
know that at the end of the game the
console or at the end of the level the
concert is going to blink a little bit
it's the screen is gonna go dark and
then you're going to go to another level
or maybe the game will end hmm does it
make any difference to the way you play
this level this is the level you're in
play it as best that you can
yes right and and regardless of what
happens on the next level if you know
the enemies will have bigger armors or
there will no not be enemies or suddenly
the game will be over and you'll put the
controller down does it really make any
difference to the way you play this
level the way you play this level is to
become the absolute best gamer you can
become yeah and that's truly the whole
trick if we manage to stop thinking
about the next level or actually just
the next move on the in the game and
just focus on this move yeah everything
becomes easy